fans ten years ago giants fan brian
stove's life was changed forever
when he was viciously attacked after a
game at dodger stadium
his recovery has been a long and trying
journey
but the process has helped him realize a
greater calling
to use his story to spread a message of
anti-bullying to our nation's youth
and he is working to change a rapidly
growing problem in our society
to the giants family brian is the living
embodiment
of true grace and resilience we are
deeply honored to be joined by brian
and the stowe family as he now takes the
mound
to throw out today's ceremonial first
pitch
and doing the catching giants assistant
coach
alyssa nackin our beloved brian stow
everyone
on the hill today for the giants opening
up their home season will be the veteran
johnny cueto
in his 14th year at the big league level
hampson off to a good start
garrett seven for 24.
here's the one-two delivery
and that's how this game gets started
and that's a change-up
and right away he just established it
lefty austin gomber for the rockies
whose first start of the year and for
colorado was last sunday against the
dodgers he gets
austin slater to start the action
slater 4 for 23
to begin the season
0-2 pitch curve ball did he go too far
he did that's strike
three josh fuentes will face johnny
cueto
he's had five hits 23 at bat so far with
one home run
kratos swivels and throws and the slider
is lined right back to cueto who makes
the catch
look out cradle takes the glove off and
he's shaking his left hand an
opportunity
for the rockies first time they've had
base runners and they have a pair aboard
for josh fuentes who
lined a shot right back to cueto stuck
the glove up and grabbed it he
felt it it took him a little while to
have the
sting get out of his left hand so
fuentes
a right-handed hitter
waits on the pitch and he bounces this
one into the hole
cut off by flores the second for one the
throw to first
double play wilmer flores
he spirited going to his left
tossed it perfectly to solano and solana
to rough
and john equator does indeed get the
double play
bottom of the fifth coming up and now
it'll be mauricio dubon
who rolled out to short in the second
inning
fastball hit to the right side mcmahon
will go to
second and pulled story off the bag
everybody is safe sometimes
ryan at second base and you want to get
the lead runner but sometimes he
tries to make the big play he had to
bond it first
but just didn't make a good enough throw
to trevor although
the rockies i think are going to
challenge that
story stayed on the bag long enough
and he might have a
he might have a legitimate argument bud
black
question is is the foot still on the bag
and it looks like it is when the ball's
in the glove
it's not going to take him long here
comes the ruling
and he is out at second base
correct call fans don't like it one out
here is charlie blackman
another fearsome slugger
got him and charlie blackman's gonna get
run blackman is just
furious and screaming and he's been
thrown out of the game
by ben may the home plate umpire here's
cj krohn with two outs
johnny cueto whines hesitate swivels
hesitates and strikes him out swinging
he threw the changeup with the
the full monty a performance art on that
one
and that is one of the strongest innings
yet for
johnny cueto and a standing ovation for
the crowd as he heads to the dugout
so with rough at first wilmer flores
to step in a walk and a strikeout in his
two
plate appearances two and two
how about the strikeout that'll work
that's huge
big strikeout for austin gomber as he
gets flores one out in the seventh
here's buster posey who's had the
giant's only hit of the day
a single to right now the stretch
3-1 pitch buster takes it's low ball
four a fastball missing
second walk of the inning
putting two men on for the giants with
one man out
and with gabriel 104 pitches that is
going to be
the end of his day
so here's brandon crawford left-handed
batter
with the bases full the runners lead
from all three bags
and the pitch crawford hits a drive into
right center field that's into the
alleyway
way back there still going one hop up
against the wall
rough scores posey scores and
dickerson will be held at third it's a
two rod double for brandon crawford
the first runs of the game two-nothing
giants so here is bowdoin
with the bases loaded two down and
yostremski at the plate
here's the 2-2 on the outside corner he
got him bowden works out of it with the
huge strikeout he's just string skiing
josh fuentes is lying to cueto and
grounded into a double play
swing and a miss he got him
seven strikeout so here's dickerson
bases loaded one out
dickerson a little looper it's gonna
fall
one run comes in and dickerson
bloops one and it's three nothing second
straight time the crawford has come up
with the bases loaded
jordan sheffield with the payoff pitch
bouncing ball to second mcmandez story
for one on the
first for a double play how about that
for jordan sheffield
fell behind 3-0 and gets a double play
so now here is hampson the leadoff man
1-1 to hampson and garrett hits it to
right field
that will stay up yastremski
has it makes the catch owings will
score sacrifice fly makes it
3-1 giants
as garrett hampson gets his sixth run
batted in
and here comes gabe kepler with the
left-handed hitting mcmahon coming up
and the fans want to see cueto
have a chance to finish the game
[Applause]
equator now at 110 pitches
and the kaepernick will go to the mound
and he's talking with cueto
he has not taken the ball from him it
looks like kaepernick is mainly talking
to buster posey
[Applause]
and he's going to leave cueto in there
up to trevor story to try and keep this
one going for the rockies
here we go 2-2 pitch bouncing ball
into right field for a base hit
they had a shift on and no chance for
solano the second baseman to get to it
with the tying run coming to the plate
it is going to end the day
for johnny cueto and you're going to
hear a great ovation for johnny cuedo
sam hilliard who came into the game when
charlie blackmon was
ejected for arguing balls and strikes
will bat for the first time against
mcgee
the left-hander throws he struck him out
swinging
another fastball he came right after him
97 miles an hour
down the middle
[Applause]
so another save for jake mcgee and one
of the first to pop out of the giants
dugout
to go out and congratulate mcgee
and his teammates is johnny cueto